David, we often talk about the bloated U.S.
budget.
What would you cut from the U.S. budget if
given a choice?
So this is a difficult conversation to have
because the reality about the budget is that
everything is a negotiation.
Not all cuts are created equal.
Not all cuts save money.
Sometimes you actually have to spend money
in order to save money by increasing efficiency.
So I think that that's important to keep in
mind.
It's also really important to look at agencies
and see which agencies are actually doing
what they were put in place to do.
Where is their efficiency?
Where is their inefficiency?
What purposes do different agencies and departments
serve?
So this is not coming from some, you know,
small government libertarian idea of let's
start cutting departments because we just
want to make government small.
This is the reality that there's probably
a lot of consolidation and things that can
be moved around.
But just like to take the lowest hanging fruit
first.
The military and Department of Defense obviously
are bloated and need to be cut.
We don't need 50 bases in Germany to the extent
Trump wants to reduce that.
I agree with that.
The way in which it's done, obviously, is
the question.
We have a massive amount.
The thing is, it's just so easy to say this.
Say, OK, I'm on the left.
We should cut.
The military will still be safe.
I think it's more interesting to look, for
example, at cutting specifically military
contractor spending.
That's a much more specific angle where the
right and many of the on the left in in Congress
just are absolutely tied to these groups that
lobby for more military contractor spending
that specifically needs to be reduced.
You can probably consolidate, for example,
you know, does TSA, Customs and Border.
Patrol people want ice abolished altogether.
There's probably a big opportunity there to
like, dissolve, reformulate, consolidate.
That would represent a cost savings.
And then there's a bunch of spend money to
save money sort of considerations.
There is a lot of stuff where we need more
money in the short term, like infrastructure,
upgrading buildings, switching federal buildings
to renewable energy, et cetera, et cetera.
We're in the short term.
We actually have to spend more over the long
term.
We will save.
The problem with these conversations about
what to cut is that once you understand, you
can't do.
I want to say this.
Everything's a negotiation.
There's tons of favors and amendments.
And this is sort of like how policy is done
right now.
And to really cut properly, to have a shot
at actually cutting the types of spending
that is the problematic spending, you need
to completely change so many aspects of our
political system.
And there's a lot of good books written about
this and articles about it.
But, you know, me listing stuff maybe is interesting
and I don't think I'd have anything super
surprising.
But what we need to actually change is the
way that this system of cronyism and, oh,
you know, wink, wink, I'll go for your amendment
if you go for mine and this poor, you know,
everybody's put the truth is we talk about
pork barrel projects.
Everybody's pork, you know, everybody's pork
is someone else's.
In many cases, community projects.
Right.
So, you know, I get you to sign off on rebuilding
some ice rinks in my district.
And that seems like pork if you're representing
Hawai and I'm in Illinois, but then you reverse
it.
And we have very similar situations looking
from Illinois over to Hawaii.
And this is really part of the problem and
part of the problem of how budgeting is done.
But all of that being said, Department of
Defense, military, absolutely huge opportunities
to cut for sure.
No question about it.
Okay.
Make sure that you don't miss today's bonus
show, which will be hosted by producer Pat.
You can get instant access by becoming a member
at join Pacman dot com or a patron at patrie
on dot com slash David Pakman show.
We will be back on Monday.
Later next week, we will be on a little David
Pakman show vacation.
We've not had one since the start of coronavirus
because there's nothing to do and nowhere
to go.
I will be doing a little traveling within
the state with a mask and with with everything,
rubber gloves, the face shields, everything.
We'll tell you more about that next week.
Pat, on the bonus show today.
I'll be back on Monday.